from beginning to end different stages  of a star's life appear in this Hubble  Space Telescope picture of what exists  in the neighborhood of a nebula a vast  cloud of dust and gas on the bottom  pillars of glowing hydrogen signal  newborn stars emerging from their dense  gaseous nurseries in the center lies a  cluster of bright hot blue stars whose  strong winds and ultraviolet radiation  have cleared away nearby material  massive and young they will soon exhaust  their nuclear fuel above and right of  the cluster is a bright supergiant  nearing the end of its life it's  surrounded by a glowing wind rejected  gas the ring structure is reminiscent of  a supernova explosion but the star is  still a few thousand years from a  fantastic finale these two small clouds  of gas and dust are similar to the disks  in which planets form so in this picture  we are not only witnessing the birth of  stars but the birth of planets too